أه أن الخدمة العامة هي حقًا
أكثر الأشياء المحفزة بالنسبة
لي ، حقيقة أنه يمكنني معرفة الاستيقاظ
في الصباح وفهم أنه في كل
مرة أذهب إلى العمل ،
أساعد شخصًا ما وأنا في
خدمة شخص ما
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى
] تعرف أن الطب مسار وظيفي رائع
إذا كنت تفكر في ذلك ، يمكنك فقط التفكير نوعًا ما في
عدد الأشياء الممكنة التي
يمكنك القيام بها ، إنها في الحقيقة مجرد قائمة لا حصر لها
لما يمكنك فعله بشهادة طبية
أو  درجة العلوم
[الموسيقى]
هناك الكثير من الطرق
المختلفة للقيام بذلك داخل
الخدمة والحكومة أو الخدمة والمنظمات غير
الحكومية أو الخدمة في أي مؤسسة
تساعد الأشخاص وتتفاعل مع
الحكومة في كثير من الأحيان في هذه العملية
ولكن هذا
شيء
كرست حقًا معظم مسيرتي المهنية